all right uh everyone uh thanks again uh
for
joining my talk uh I'm not sure right
places you joining a good evening good
morning good night to you so so I'm
going to talk about python driven
portfolios bu year practice for
efficient uh Investments uh so I'm going
to uh cover bunch of interesting stuff
in theoretical aspects as well as
practical approach of stock and uh uh
and some quick pointers here like you
know if you're already uh have some
knowledge on finance then I think it
will be easy for you to follow the talk
otherwise to the finance and all that
then I think it shouldn't be a problem
but I I believe that know by the end of
the talk you are still able to kind
thought what we have discussed here okay
so some Shameless promotion about me uh
I'm basically as for data scientist and
uh manager uh where I the team of data
and team at my work uh apart from my uh
profession so I been involved in a lot
of Open Source communities where I
perform different roles and
responsibilities each of these
organizations so you can look at some
the organizations are listed in my slide
and other thing is I always look for an
opportunity to share my knowledge so so
whereever I get a speaking opportunity I
always like to speak and share my
knowledge on
platforms uh yeah also we two hats here
on one is on industry side as well as
something I also have hat on academic
side as well so I also mentor on
Commercial platforms and Community
platforms like you know T and top and uh
if you want to connect me or if you have
any feedback that you want to give my
talk or anything these are my social
handlings feel free to write it over
there and I'll be responding to each and
every message that I receive on these
platforms so without any further let's
get started
uh uh so they say money talks but all
mine ever says is a goodbye because
that's why I'm here today to talk and
share or learn about building efficient
portfolios by way this was a joke but
it's a fact okay uh and uh yeah one
important thing here is uh disclaimer uh
so uh so my talk does not provide any
Financial advice I do not claim as a
financial expert here uh so the purpose
of the stock and the object of the stock
is to share knowledge and you know and
learning so an educative purpose so so
so take take of and if you like play
around your own data and see how you get
result so let's start with the portfolio
uh what exactly is a portfolio so a
portfolio refers to the bucket of
financial instrument that you know
invest or individual cods so it can be a
bunch of different financial instruments
like you know the stocks bonds
Commodities which you are seeing on my
slide or like mutual funds Etc so the OB
of our financial portfolio is to like
you know generate wealth and you know
over the investing over the of investing
period and achieve it Financial
objective so that's the main goal of
portfolio and portfolio management test
so this is one of the key Concept in our
main topic so that's the reason why I
thought of starting out with a portfolio
here so before we actually uh so before
we actually get into the main theme of
our topic I just want to highlight you
about the man behind the uh behind the
topic which we are discussing so there
he is har M so so har Mich is a famous
American economic scientist and he's a
father of modern portfolio P we going to
talk in the overall presentation right
uh so
and Har m is a very popular figure if
you go to Google and find just quickly
do a search right you'll get a bunch of
like information about him so that
popular he is and he won in Nobel Prize
in 1990 uh in economic s for developing
the modern portfolio KD so that's it's a
great thing and uh so in the in the
world of investing uh so realizing how
risk is important alongside with
produ so that's what Mar has spent his
life in studying this balance through
Modern portfolio Theory
so and some of his work has been like
you know popular Concepts like you know
diversication overall portfolio risk and
returns which you will be seen detail in
the next coming fles all of these are
like very popular concept and very
widely used in industries of like
organizations so that's what these
things are and the saddest part here is
so the of
Finance no more recently past couple of
months back but his the great work has
been like you know Prett efficient and
been wi used in Industries uh these
days so there comes our main topic
called modern portfolio Theory so there
are a lot of a traditional definitions
which you can see about mp on Google but
to put it in a very simple way right
it's a framework for evaluating risk and
return uh now you might be wondering
okay I'll skip about
my like you know self intro here but
okay let
me talk about the important things here
so yeah I'll start with the disclaimer
here so again so the talk is not to
provide any Financial advice neither I
claim myself finan here the main
objective and over OB of this talk is to
like you know share knowledge and more
of like you know on education purpose so
that know if you feel interested you can
play around with it so there's no
related to provide any Financial from
the
stock uh yeah so start with a basic
concept called portfolio so uh so
portfolio refers to like you know of a
different financial instruments that an
investor or individual fors so it can be
like you know different financial
instruments like you know your stocks
bonds Commodities like you know your
mutual funds Debs right so the overall
like the object of a financial portfolio
folio is to generate wealth over
investing and achieve its Financial
objective so that's what the portfolio
and portfolio management thinks to in
real time so which is one of the key
thing in our main topics so that's the
reason why I started with this uh
concept there uh and uh again so some
some of the points which I told you
earlier while I was m so what I was
saying is if you are familiar with the
finance right then it will be easy for
you to follow the flow of the stop if
you are not familiar the finance I
believe that you know by the end of this
session you are still able to connect
the dots for short so that's how so I'll
not talk about more complex Theory or
more complex terminologies I'll try to
put it I'll try to put it or explain
everything in a very simple way so that
you know you can gra the context if okay
so before we go we are going to talk
about the main theme of our topic we
need to understand the man behind this
topic uh man behind this it is nothing
but Haring micro so he's like you know
popular American economic scientist and
uh he's also called as a father of
modern portfolio Theory and for that he
won in Nobel Prize in
1990 for developing with Mod portfolio
Theory so imagine in the world of
investing right so realizing how risk is
important alongside with RS is crucial
right that's that's so so this man has
spent his entire life in studying this
balance between the risk and return so
his work has been popularly recognized
and it's been widely used in
Industries today so that that popular is
work is all about so like you know
you'll seeing the concept like you know
diversification over over Port overall
portfolio risk and so all of these
things you'll be seeing practically like
to the next couple of slides as well and
the saddest part here is uh so the o
your Finance like you know there's no
more I think a couple of months back he
he passed away but uh but his work the
way he work the work have done in
finance and investment like why
[Music]
appreciate so here comes our main topic
called uh modern portfolio Theory and
MPT uh it's like uh so there are a lot
of traditional definitions you can see
on the internet about MPT but to put it
in a very simple way right it's a
framework for Val in risk and return uh
so some of you might be wondering it
sounds very simple but what you have to
understand is prior to npt there was no
standardized methodology or a framework
for evaluating risk and return so that's
ke about MPT which has bought a lot of
changes in the industry and again it's a
mathematical process which allows users
examined returns for the given risk
level of course there a lot of
underlying mathematical Al
formulas and techniques which are
involved in order to achieve this thing
but don't worry I'm not going to show
you about all those complex formulas or
like I'm not going to show you any
mathematics here because I really don't
want to scare you all instead I I show
you things in a very simple
way simple piece of python code that you
can uh get things done uh so MP and it
assume that all investor risk of let's
for for instance like you know if if you
have a return returns of like you know
the low low VAR portfolios and high
portfolio with same returns right
definitely will try to choose less
investment L less low variance returns
right so end of the nobody wants to go
for a high RK or high right because
nobody wants to L the money and the
beauty of MBT is it encases
diversification of assets so for
instance if you have a high variance
portfolio X and with diversification
assets like you know Y and Z so so your
XY will not have any direct correlation
and which puts in very diversification
asset and that will give you a great
number of return instead of like losing
everything so that's how that's Beauty
about
the so that's main the of uh NPD here
and uh when it comes to Industry right
it's a key tool for a lot of asset
managers and Robo advisers like you know
because they use uh to build a
strategies of like you know Buy and Hold
Strat with us in so that powerful this
is in real time as
well to explain you in a very simple
process about MPT rights so so this is a
simple example where you can try to
understand MPT process here so imagine
that you know we have a $1 million
million dollar uh that splits between
like you know with the fund X and fund Y
which means that you know you are
investing $700,000 in X fund and you are
trying to invest $300 in fund wi right
with an expected return of 7% and 10% so
now how this calculation will happen see
something like that if you look at this
breakdown which I am
like uh which I am trying to point out
here is so we have invested $7,000
$700,000 an expected of 7%
and which is like you know when you
calculate this you get $49,000 out of it
similarly for $300,000 for y fund with a
10% expected return you get a $30,000
expected return so when you sum of this
both expected return right so it's like
you know 49,000 and 30,000 which is like
you know $79,000 is your combined
expected return and then when you divide
this combined expected return with your
to Total portfolio amount uh so this is
your expected portfolio return
percentage so this is what which is
where we are trying to get your combined
portfolio percentage value for $1
million $1 million investment which has
been spitted into two different on so
that's how it works in the Real Time
with a simple example but again this is
a very simple example but in real time
we do a lot of data that I show you when
we move on to the demo part so that's
how the exactly the process works of MPT
in a real
time and uh yeah okay let me I think
should
change okay again when it comes to as I
mentioned there are a lot of
mathematical modelings are there in MPT
so we focus only on the foundation of
mathematical model because there's a lot
of complex things which I don't want to
discuss or which want conf we'll start
with we start
with aspect which are really important
to understand the intuition behind MPT
so once you get a fair understanding on
this Foundation I think you can
gradually build upon for both for this
Advanced model and play around with it
so for the OB is to focus only on the
foundation aspects in this
St so we'll start with the first risk
and expected return return so this is
exactly how we try to
derive these are the key pointers where
we try to identify the risk and expected
return to the our MPD process risk Aion
as I mentioned so every investor is
aware of the risk associated within the
empty portfolio so that because they're
trying to if they want to get more
returns so they be high risk they want
to get less return is like
less the relationship of a risk and
return works onev so when you are trying
to expect more money then you definitely
have to take the more risk so that's how
that risk and return relationship clly
Works in modeling process and uh and uh
while so R risk can be measured by the
standard division of returns assuming
certain parameters how returns are
distributed so standard division plays a
very key role in terms of identifying
our like you know expected and risk and
expected returns while we are building a
portfolio model right optimization model
we'll try to calculate both the
portfolio return and the portfolio
volatility so the portfolio return is
nothing but your the combination of
consolidation of result of your
individual assets which has been
proportionately distributed in your ass
the one which the one example which have
seen earlier so the vity is nothing but
how much risk have been associated with
within those assets so it's like you
know how two assets are correlated each
other so this is where you have more
volatility and more R because if they
correlated it means that they are super
fast increasing Trend or there can be a
super fast decreasing Trend so this is
where your risk lies because
divers so that's how the r and expect
and Factor Works don't worry about like
you know all of this Theory but when we
try to practically put it everything in
a code right you when you see the code
part I think you will able to clearly
get out of what we are trying to uh do
with all the terminologies or what we
try to cover everything you will see in
practically when we move on to
code again as I mentioned
diversification is really important it's
a track of modern portfolio Theory
because it helps us to eliminate or
reduce the risk when we have a
diversified asset so the impact of one
asset may like you know may try to
fulfill the back with other Diversified
assets so one asset loss can be Tred to
in put in the other asset so that you
know you'll get a balanced uh
returns rather than losing everything so
that's how the
diversification risk works here and uh
yeah so as I mentioned it reduces the
risk so risk can be a two types here
like you know syncratic risk and non
syntic so OS syncratic is something
where diversification works well because
it it's specifically focused on specific
assets so this is where you can put the
diversification and try to eliminate the
risk but when it comes to system itic
right it is something like you know
where it has impacted the entire market
like you know your entire stock market
has put it in the risk so this is where
you cannot TR put the diversification
it's very hard to put a divers for
entire stock market right so you cannot
work
on and you order to build a very
Diversified portfolio right so it's good
to include your like you know Assets in
like you know various Industries various
uh instrument and at the various risk
level so that know your portfolio is
well Diversified so that's what exactly
the portfolio managers and Robo advises
will do your money when you try to
invest
portfolio and as I mentioned so perfect
POS perfect positive correlation if
there is a positive correlation in your
graph it means that no where there is a
high level of risk because when there is
a positive correlation between different
assets it means that either they are in
increasing Trend or whether it can be a
decreasing Trend so there is no
diversification involved here right so
this is where you see a lot of TR here
but uh when when you hold assets so when
your assets are moving in an opposite
direction which means that whether they
are negative correlated or moving in
other way so this is where your D reg
works well because when you have issue
with when you have risk inir and have
not other other assets you try to put
that into this so that you can diers
well Diversified and you can hold that
asset and that will give you a duty of
returns rather than losing everything
that's what the diversification is all
about and uh so when you try to identify
the like you know risk and return levels
of your portfolio so we we try to plot a
visual called efficient Frontier so
which where we are trying to figure out
how risk
optimiz or how risk optimization we used
to get the return Returns what we are
expecting so this blot helps us to
identify that how much this Optimizer
involed and how much returns you are
getting it so the x- axis basically
shows your risk factor and the y axis
basically shows the return Factor here
and you can look at the so this is what
the line is something called the
efficient Frontier line and you can look
at this a parabola it's a shape of a
parabola right so so the L the line
on and are nothing but your optimized
portfolio that generat return
for and the line below points are
nothing but not optimized and that's how
the efficient Frontier plot Works uh I
think uh this is pretty much theory that
because I don't know to B with lot the
so let me show you some action now that
how we can build a efficient Frontier
with like you know real time let me go
back to my
code okay there it is should be
somewhere
here oh
no sorry my
bad so yeah so this is The Notebook
which I have created for this
demonstration uh so you can see that uh
so you need to the ob is to walk you
through the portfolio Theory so as I
import message ects like you know you
are data manipulation performing some
statistical calculations and Performing
some scientific computation functions
and plotting for that so I put all of
these different libraries here so you
can see so when it comes to data
Gathering so it has five diverse ETF
assets like you know which has a
treasury bond which has a price of gold
which hasp finded index which has ndaq
large Cap Technology index and also the
Equity market so I bought a data from
all these different five ETF assets so
how I pulling this real time data is
through with the yaho finance so the
data period which I'm pulling is from
2018 to 22 because I just pulled the
four years data uh ini I thought of
pulling it 10 years but no considering
the competition power of mine and all my
person system so I just four years data
and all so that's it so next what I'm
doing is I'm trying to get this data R
this data real time so for that what I
have done is I written a custom function
where I am passing my ass data where I'm
passing my start and end of the data and
so when I get this so I get a lot of
different Columns of data so it can be a
volume it can be our date everything so
but instead I was just focusing only on
the adjusted close value because
adjusted close price is something that
which I'm really interested to
understand how this prices have been uh
moving and how these prices are
fluctuating so that's the reason why I'm
picking only the justed close price uh
so I passed my ticket here started
everything and everything I saved in the
data called Data so once I pull this so
there I can see that you know my asset
data for all this five different assets
so next thing is what I'm trying to do
is trying to calculate the risk and
return so which I shown you here so as I
mentioned so so investors always starty
to prefer with less risk portfolio than
they have same RS right when they have
more risk and lower risk with same RS
people always try to preest less
portfolio right uh and there's only a
slight possibility that people might go
with the high expected risk but uh only
when they promis or they try to see that
know getting for high this is a slightly
rare case in real time uh next what I'm
doing is I'm calculating the daily
returns so since I got a daily
prices of the daily prices of adjusted
close so next what I'm trying to do I'm
trying to convert this daily price into
logs so that what I do is I quickly
written this function called calculating
dat and with np. block function what
I'll do is I can convert this daily
prices into a loot returns and I put
those daily returns into a variable
called The Daily in a variable called
daily R my so you can see these are my
daily Returns value similarly I also
done for the annual returns as well see
it's pretty same so just pass my annual
return value and there you can see my
annual return values so next what I've
done is I try to visualize and see how
my dailys looks like and if you see this
is how my daily return lot looks all the
F so you can see um so it's simple so
with my plotly plot function I could
just pass my index and value so and
there you can see
the they for all my years and you can
see the fluctuations of all these
different assets right for example if
you see the FNP 500 has a highest
fluctuations graph especially the 2020
mid followed by wwo so you can see so
these kind of insights you will try to
get it from your daily R calculations
that's what next what I have done is I
try to calculate the co returns which
means that I try to bring the co Matrix
of daily so this is what my daily Co and
similarly I have also got the co
for annual returns as well so the reason
behind for giving 252 is nothing but so
in in 365 out of 365 days we only have a
250 days that consider as that considers
as a trading days where your Market will
be open rest of the days we have
like so next what I'm done is next I'm
trying to declare weights with this
simple piece of code so basically what
this code generates it basically
generates stand random set of Weights
that that can be allocated with
allocated to the funds within a
portfolio it's like you know where
you're trying to put your all of the
money into the assets of a different
assets within that portfolio so so the
reason so and the thing is when you try
to sum up all of these weight right it
equals to one so that's thing if your
weights are something where you're not
trying to get it equal to one so there
will missing so I just written the
formula when I print the weight so this
is what the weights I got it from my uh
follow all of the so now that we got all
these weights so I'm trying to calculate
my expected portfolio return but simply
by passing my daily return means and
weights where I got my expected
portfolio written value and similarly I
also try to get the variance values as
well it's simple that know where I try
to pass the three three parameters with
the MP do function and also so here
where I'm trying to do is so where in
this case where I'm weight has been
transposed from know column index to row
index if if I don't transform the weight
here then it will be a big mess where
have to calculate the Vance we have to
calculate weight for all the variances
for all the weight so that's big mess
here so instead of that so I just simply
passed all of these things in this
particular function and there I got my
portfolio variance and vitality values
so so suiz it so we have what we have
done is so we basically fix the data and
we have tried to calculate the portfolio
variance and expect return of our values
on one single weight only on one single
but if if you in order to get a more
optimal solution we need to perform this
same iterative process on Thousand
number of weight so that you know we get
a weight
understanding oh hey I'm sorry to
interrupt you but we're uh at time would
you just like to direct your uh
questions to
Discord all right so I'll quickly show
you what uh I want to show on the final
plot so I'll run the portfolio
simulation and on on on all these
headsets just give me a three minutes
I'll just wrap it up uh
so 2 minutes I just want to show you the
final plot visual that uh the
is it
fine uh yeah we're really at time I mean
I'm sorry but
like all right so basically this is what
my uh the final outcomes which you
ploted right uh so you can see the
efficient this is your optimal short
ratio and your portfolio expected
returns based on this people will try to
make a better investment DEC whether
they want to hold our so you can I can
share the notebook and feel free to play
around with it
so my bad that know initially I was in M
otherwise I would have covered all of
this stuff yeah I'll be happy to P
questions uh in the Discord and yeah
these are some of the reference if you
want to like you know uh play around
with it yeah thanks again and if you
have any feedback and if you want to
reach out so feel free to get in touch
with this things yeah now